in today's video from free pilot
training I'm going to explain in detail
how to use the manual e6b flight
computer AKA The Wiz will this device
allows you to make nearly any
calculation you might need in flight and
is especially handy once you start
getting into CrossCountry flying when
you first look at it the e6b can seem a
little bit intimidating and complicated
almost like a piece of ancient alien
technology that was left behind from the
Roswell incident an extraterrestrial
device which was given to the Israelites
during their 40-year wandering through
the desert yeah probably not but
actually the old WIS will is a lot
simpler than you might think and it's
extremely easy to use the front side
where we'll be doing most of our time
Fuel and distance calculations operates
based on the 60 to1 rule this principle
works because there's 60 minutes in an
hour so basically this thing is just
multiplying and dividing our distances
and fuel by 60 that's all it's doing I
know you were probably hoping it was
aliens but unfortunately that's not the
case this time it looks something that
you know Came From Outer Space it's the
only conclusion that you can draw anyway
now that you know that the e6p is going
to make a lot more sense when you go to
use it now before I start showing you
how to use this thing I want to point
out one more thing The Whiz will will
calculate miles per hour and Knots
exactly the same the 60 to1 rule applies
the same to statute miles as it does for
nautical miles and I suppose if you
really wanted you could probably also
make calculations in kilometers as well
and this is really nice because you can
actually take your flight computer on
road trips and practice making
calculations when you see road signs
that tell you the distance remaining to
your destination you want to have the
driver set the cruise control and it's
kind of cool to see how close you can
get all right let's take a closer look
at this thing on the outer ring we
always find our distance that's going to
be either nautical miles statute miles
or whatever then when we start Mak fuel
calculations we'll be using the outer
scale for that as well then on the inner
scale we have our time and for almost
every problem we solve our time is going
to be on the inner scale the exception
to this is when we convert back and
forth from True air speed to calibrated
air speed but we'll discuss that more in
a few minutes and because we find time
on the inside of the scale these numbers
in here are all multipliers of 60
because we're either multiplying or
dividing by 60 and by rotating the scale
that that's all we're doing is creating
a 60:1 ratio that's it you still think
it might have been aliens and the answer
is a potential yes now one other thing
you need to know is that there are no
single digits on these scales notice
here on the outer scale that there isn't
a one there's only a 10 this 10 can
represent one it can represent 10 it can
represent 100 a th000 or basically any
multiplier of 10 the important thing to
remember is that if you turn this into a
one by moving a decimal over you need to
do it to the number on the other side as
well for example if my flight computer
is set in this configuration and my
distance is one mile I'll use the 10
because there isn't a one now I move the
decimal over to turn this into a one
when I look across I read 11 minutes but
because I move the decimal to the left
on this side I also need to move the
decimal over to the left on the inner
scale as well so my answer in this case
will be 1.1 minutes not 11 there's one
exception to this rule anytime my speed
is faster than 60 the 10 on the inner
scale is rotated to the right of the 10
on the outer scale the numbers in
between these two tens will be one digit
off and if you add a zero to the outer
scale the inner scale will read
correctly for example if I add a zero to
make this 120 miles the number I read
across from that will still be 70
minutes because it's in between the two
t if you forget this little trick that's
okay you can still just use a little
Common Sense too because it's going to
be pretty obvious that 700 minutes is
not the correct answer and now that you
understand that I'll show you how to
make these calculations the first
calculation you might want to make is to
find out how fast you're going this
one's pretty simple in order to find
that we need to know two things first we
need to know the distance that we
traveled and we also need to know how
long it took us to get there let's start
with an easy one let's say we traveled
two statute miles and it took us 2
minutes to get there now you probably
already know the answer without using
this thing but we'll do a harder one
here in a second start with your
distance on the outer scale if you ever
forget these whiz Wheels usually have
markings on the outer scale to remind
you that that's for distance and we said
our distance was two statute miles so
let's use this two because there's not a
two on here then we'll find our time on
the inner scale now the inner dial has
two scales on it on the outer part of
the dial you'll find minutes and on the
inner part of the dial you'll find hours
so let's rotate the scale until 2
minutes lines up with two statute miles
once we do that we want to know our
speed and the way we express that is how
far we went in 1 hour 1 hour is 60
minutes and so the 60 is typically
marked with a nice big arrow and
sometimes labeled with the word rate so
we will find our speed right across from
that arrow in this example we can see
that we're traveling 60 statute miles in
60 minutes or 60 M hour very simple
let's make it a little bit more
difficult let's say we traveled 80
nautical miles and it took us 70 minutes
to get there now how fast are we going
well let's see let's find our distance
of 80 nautical miles in the outer scale
and rotate our time of 70 minutes until
it lines up with the 80 now we want to
know our speed in nautical miles hour
and 1 hour is 60 minutes so we simply
look across from the 60 Arrow again
let's see here's 65 66 67 looks like
just over 68 knots so our speed is 68
knots let's try one more let's say we
traveled 110 nautical miles and it took
us 1 hour and 20 minutes first let's
find 110 nautical miles on the outer
ring as you can see we just add a zero
and this 11 becomes
110 now we rotate the dial until an hour
and 20 minutes on the inner scale lines
up with that number and as you can see 1
hour and 20 minutes is also 80 minutes
then once again we look for our rate
triangle at 60 minutes and now we can
see that we're traveling just over 82
knots too easy now I want to point out
something anytime you come up with a
speed in relation to your distance over
the ground this is your ground speed
let's back up and discuss that just for
a second there are basically four types
of air speed that you need to know about
as a pilot first is your true air speed
your true air speed is basically the
speed at which your aircraft is
traveling through the air around you
this is not what you see on your air
speed indicator and the reason for this
is because as the air gets thinner there
are fewer air molecules that can enter
your pedo system and that air pressure
entering the pedo tube is what your air
speed indicator is measuring so as the
air gets thinner your indicated air
speed will decrease but your true air
speed will actually increase because
thinner air means there's less drag on
the aircraft now if you remember from my
previous videos the air gets thinner or
the pressure decreases anytime you
increase your altitude and anytime the
temperature rises and that's because
warm air is less dense than cool air so
your true air speed is directly related
to the outside air temperature and the
air pressure indicated air speed on the
other hand is what you actually see on
your air speed indicator this is not how
fast you're traveling through the air
around you it's how fast your airplane
thinks it's traveling through the air
around you all the airplane cares about
is air molecules going through the ped2
it doesn't know when you're at higher
altitudes and that there aren't as many
air molecules up at higher altitud tudes
it also doesn't know when some of the
air that's hitting the front of the pedo
tube is wind or when it's just air from
the airplane Moving Straight Ahead it's
measuring all of the relative wind
entering the pedo tube next we have our
calibrated air speed and this one's a
little bit weird it's what your
indicated air speed should be if
Engineers were able to create a perfect
system to measure air speed the problem
that occurs when your airplane flies
through the air is that the pitch of the
aircraft changes anytime you change your
speed flap configuration and gear
configuration and because of that the
air can hit the pedo tube at different
angles so this causes errors and every
aircraft is different so you have to
look in the P to see what the
calibration errors are for the airplane
that you're flying last but not least we
have our ground speed this is the actual
speed that we're traveling over the
ground and this depends on two things
our true air speed and the wind and this
is the speed we need to find in anytime
we're making timing calculations because
unfortunately you can't just look down
at your air speed indicator and come up
with these calculations and that's
because indicated air speed doesn't
account for air density and wind we're
going to get more into that in just a
minute but let's move on with some of
these calculations another calculation
that you might need to make with the e6b
is to find out how long it will take you
to get somewhere let's say you're
traveling at 120 mph this time and we're
going to be traveling 180 statute miles
how long will it take us to get there
well we already know our rate in 60
minutes is 120 mil so let's rotate the
rate Arrow over to 12 remember distance
is on the outer scale so let's look for
180 on the outside there it is now we
simply look across from that to see that
it should take us 90 minutes to get
there our rid arrow is above 60 knots
and the numbers we're looking for are in
between the 2 10 so 90 minutes is the
correct answer not 900 we could also
look at our hour scale and that would be
an hour and 30 minutes now what if I'm
traveling the same speed and I'm only
going 13 miles our flight computer is
already set up now how long will it take
well let's look up here at the 13 on the
outer ring and that's because 13 was our
distance then we simply look across from
that remember the arrow is 60 so it
looks like 65 so we simply move the
decimal over to get 6.5 minutes remember
65 is in between the two 10 so it's one
digigit off so it's going to take us 6
minutes and 30 seconds to go 13 mil next
you may need to calculate how far you
traveled let's go back to knots again
let's say we're traveling 90 knots and
it took us 1 hour and 40 minutes to get
there how far did we go let's start with
our rate of 60 minutes and put that on
our distance of 90 nautical miles and
that gets us our 90 nautical milph or 90
knots now we simply look for our time on
the inner ring we said that it took us 1
hour and 40 minutes to get there so how
far did we travel let's look at the
inner scale for 1 hour and 40 minutes
which is also 100 minutes and it looks
like we traveled 150 nautical miles what
if we're traveling 73 knots and it took
us 73 minutes now how far did we go
let's start with our rate unless your
clock has 48 minutes in an hour because
you're a flat earther your rate is once
again 60 minutes so let's rotate at to
73 nautical miles on the outer ring
let's look at our time on the inner
scale of 73 minutes and we can read our
distance once again on the outer ring it
looks to me like we travel just under 89
nautical miles the next type of
calculation that the old WIS will can
give us is how fast we're going once
again this is our ground speed and
that's because we're coming up with
these numbers in relation to our time
and distance over the ground let's say
we traveled 16 statute miles and it took
us 13 minutes to get there how fast are
we going we know our distance is 16
statute miles so let's find that on the
outer scale then we know it took us 13
minutes so let's rotate the 13 on the
inner scale to match the 16 now we need
to look for our rate and once again we
want to know our speed in relation to 60
minutes so let's look over here at the
rate triangle it looks like our speed is
just under 74 mph now if you're a flat
earther I'll throw you a bone and you
can find your speed right right here at
the 48 minute mark it looks like your
speed in this example is 59
mpf and for those of you who don't know
what that stands for that's miles per
Flat Earth hour and you know we all
laugh at this but this might actually
come in handy if you need to know the
distance you'll travel in 48 minutes at
that speed and in this case we know
it'll be 59 miles so your rate might not
always be 60 Minutes it just depends on
the information you need at the time
okay for the rest of the video I'm going
to be using knots because I hate using
miles hour when I'm talking about flying
so anytime you hear me say miles for the
rest of the video you can assume I'm
talking about nautical miles I just
wanted you to see that it doesn't matter
what system of measurement you use the
flight computer works the same for
everything crazy huh so you're surmising
the technology was given to these people
the engineering knowledge because this
screams mathematics I will certainly
concur to this extent some one or
someone
had extraordinary knowledge here this is
not easy to build no let's do another
one of these really quick now let's say
I flew 110 miles and it took me 67
minutes to get there now how fast am I
going once again we'll start with our
distance on the outer ring and rotate
our 67 minute Mark to line up with that
now we find our rate triangle and read
our speed right next to it looks like
we're flying just over 98 knots ground
speed all right before we start talking
about calculating fuel I just want to
leave you with a couple things to
remember first is that there basically
three parts to all these calculations
you have your outer ring which is where
we find our distance then you have your
inner ring which is where you find your
time and then you have your rate and the
key here with the rate is that it's
going to be 60 because there's 60
minutes in an hour so if you want to
know your speed in Nal miles hour or
regular miles hour this is what you want
to use last but not least you need to
use common sense to make sure these
calculations are accurate does the
number I'm seeing make sense or do I
need to add or remove a decimal I gave
you my trick with the two1 but if that
doesn't work for you just think about
the result for just a second and make
sure these numbers make sense now let's
talk about how much fuel we're going to
be using this one is really simple and
it works the exact same way as the
distance hey we were visited by ETS okay
not quite it also uses the the 60 to1
rule But first you need to know some
basic information about your airplane
before you can start making calculations
with this thing if you take a look at
the performance charts for your airplane
you'll notice that for a given pressure
altitude a certain temperature and a
specific power setting your aircraft
will burn a certain rate of fuel let's
say for example I'm flying at a pressure
altitude of 4,000 ft at Standard air
temperature and I'll be using a power
setting of 2,400 RPM according to this
chart I'm going to be burning about 8.5
Gall per hour now someone made a very
good point in the comments on my last
video and I thought I'd mention that
today as you probably know Standard air
temperature is 15° C at the surface and
as you may remember with a standard laps
rate of 2° every th000 ft technically
standard temperature at 4,000 ft is no
longer 15° if you do the math you'll see
that it's actually 7° so that's
something to keep in mind when you're
looking at these charts I want to give a
shout out to John for pointing that out
to me it's important to know where all
these calculations come from because
when it comes to fuel you want to be as
accurate as possible anyway now that we
know we're burning 8.5 gallons per hour
what if I fly for 2 and 1/2 hours how
much fuel would I burn in that amount of
time this is very similar to our
distance first we know that we're
burning 8.5 gallons each hour so let's
make our rate 1 hour because that's 60
minutes and we'll rotate that over to
8.5 in that case we'll be on the 85 Mark
here then we'll look around the inner
scale for a 2 and 1/2 hours now this is
where you can fall into a trap your
first thought maybe to look for a 25 on
the inner scale for 2 and 1/2 hours you
can't do that these are minutes so you
either need to use the hour scale on the
inside or convert to minutes and use the
outer part of the inner scale as you can
see that would be 150 minutes so in this
example we can see that we're burning
21.1 Gall in 2 and 1/2 hours now now you
probably just noticed something my 210
trick really doesn't work for the fuel
burn calculations like it does the
timing and distance calculations for
this one you just have to use a little
bit of Common Sense and think about how
much fuel you're burning per hour which
one makes more sense 211 gallons in 2
and half hours or
21.1 let's do another one let's say I'm
burning n gallons an hour now and I fly
for 4 hours how many gallons would I
burn well let's rotate the outer rate
Mark over to the nine and see it looks
like 4 hours is 240 minutes and we'll
just look across from there on the outer
scale to see that we'll burn about 36
gallons now the cool thing about these
whiz Wheels is that once you set them up
with a rate it's really easy to find the
answers to other problems really quickly
let's say I wanted to know how long it
would take me to burn 30 gallons at the
same rate all I need to do is look over
here at the 30 gallon mark on the outer
ring to see that we would have about 200
minutes of flight time here's a handy
one at night we need to have 45 minutes
of fuel on board to land how many
gallons would that be well if our rate
is still 9 gallons per hour we're all
set up already let's look over here at
45 minutes on the inner scale and it
looks like we need 65 66 67 we need
about 6.8 gallons to be legal when we
land let's change this around a little
bit let's say I flew for 50 minutes and
I burned 10 gallons how many gallons per
hour did I burn well let's find 10
gallons on the outer ring and rotate 50
50 minutes up to that Mark now we can
read our rate under the rate triangle it
looks like we burn 12 Gall per hour it's
amazing how this thing can calculate so
many different things is it possible
this technology came from Aliens the
ancient alien theory answers that exact
question and the answer is yes now let's
use these calculations to solve a few
different problems that you might see in
the air plane let's say we're flying
across country from CC Arkansas over to
West Memphis after our departure we flew
over our first waypoint at 1347 local
time then we flew over our second
waypoint at 1358 local what time will we
arrive at our
destination well the first thing we need
to do is to find our distance and we can
use our plotter to get that and when I
lay it on here I'm showing the distance
to be 17 nautical miles then from that
Waypoint to our destination it looks
like we have another 41 nautical miles
to go now what we want to do is to find
our round speed we arrived at our first
way point at 1347 and our second wayp
point at 1358 1358 - 1347 = 11 it took
us 11 minutes to get from our first
Waypoint to our second wayp point so
let's pull out our flight computer now
to find our ground speed the distance of
our first leg was 17 miles and the time
it took us to get there was 11 minutes
so we'll rotate 11 minutes on the inner
scale over to 17 miles now we simply
look at our rate triang angle it looks
like our ground speed is about 93 knots
now our flight computer is already set
up all we have to do to find our
estimated time of arrival is to take the
remaining distance which we said was 41
miles and find that on the outer ring of
our flight computer here it is down here
at the bottom so now we can see that
it's going to take us 25 26 26.2 4 about
26.6 minutes so that would be 26 minutes
and 36 seconds so we can just add that
to the time at our last wayp point which
we said was
1358 so we'll reach West Memphis at 1424
and 36 seconds now how much fuel will we
burn from the last Waypoint to our
destination let's say we looked in the
PO and it says we're going to be burning
9.5 gallons per hour let's rotate our
rate over to 9.5 and now we're all set
up we just calculated that it's going to
take us 26.6 minutes to get there so
let's look for 26.6 minutes on the the
inner scale and it's super easy to find
because we just found it a second ago
and it looks like we're going to be
burning about 4.2 gallons of fuel let's
do another one of these really quick
this time let's say we're flying from
West Memphis over to carile municipal
airport as we fly over our first
Waypoint we notice that the time is
1517 and when we fly over our second
Waypoint the time is
1529 if our speed doesn't change what
time will we arrive at our destination
okay so first of all we need to figure
out how long it took us to fly this leg
if we subtract 1517 from 1529 we can see
that it took us 12 minutes now how far
was that leg let's pull out our plotter
and see it looks to me like it's right
at 20 mil and from there to our
destination it's another 26 miles so now
we can find 20 mil on our flight
computer and rotate 12 minutes on the
inner scale over to that and now we can
find our speed AC cross from the rate
triangle it looks to me like we're
traveling exactly 100 knots okay so now
our flight computer is already set up if
we want to know how long it will take us
to travel the last 26 miles of our trip
all we have to do is look across from
the 26 mile mark on the outer ring it
looks like 15.6 minutes or 15 minutes
and 36 seconds so let's add that to the
time at our last wayp point so we'll
arrive at our destination at 1544 and3 6
seconds now let's say we're burning 8.2
gallons of fuel per hour how much fuel
will we burn in that amount of time well
let's move our rate over to 8.2 gallons
per hour and see once the ratio is set
up let's look at our time of 15.6
minutes on the inner ring and move out
from there to get our total gallons
burned I'm getting 2.14 gallons now
before we move over to the wind side of
the flight computer I want to take a
look at a couple more things you can do
with the conversion side of the flight
computer computer one important thing
this thing will calculate is your
density altitude this is extremely
important when we're talking about
aircraft performance the higher the
density altitude the less performance
you'll have and the longer your takeoffs
and landings will be in order to find
density altitude you need to know your
pressure altitude and the current
temperature now I've discussed in
several of my videos how to find your
pressure altitude but a really quick way
is to Simply dial in the Standard air
pressure of 29.9 2 in into the kesman
window of your altimeter and this will
give you the current pressure altitude
wherever you are and as you can see here
I have 29.92 set in my altimeter and it
looks like my pressure altitude here is
about 650 ft now let's say the
temperature outside today is 20° C now
we can find our density altitude with
the whiz willll first let's find 650 ft
in this little window as you can see we
kind of have to guess where that is then
we rotate our temperature of 20° over to
that spot now we can see our density
altitude in this little window right
here in the center it's just above 1,000
ft I'm going to say we have a density
altitude of 1,200 ft and we're going to
be talking about density altitude and
performance more in a future episode for
now this is a really quick and easy way
to get it next we can convert between
true and calibrated altitude true
altitude is the actual height in MSL
your aircraft is is above sea level
airports mountains and other permanent
things are measured in true altitude and
what you actually see on your altimeter
is actually slightly different than that
as you may remember from my lesson on
altimeters the altitude you read in the
airplane or your indicated altitude can
be affected by temperature changes in
air pressure and errors in your
altimeter calibrated altitude is what
your altimeter should read at a certain
true altitude but it doesn't account for
the instrument errors because every
altimeter is a little bit different so
this is the easiest way to compare the
true altitude of something to what you
can expect to see on your altimeter
minus the very slight errors that your
altimeter might have anyway if you know
your pressure altitude and the
temperature you can compare your true
altitude with your calibrated altitude
let's say you're flying towards a big
mountain and you want to see how high
you need to fly in order to clear the
top of it you know the top is a true
altitude of 10,000 ft MSL and you're
currently flying at an indicated
altitude of 10,500 ft and the current
altimeter setting is
3012 and let's say that's accurate are
you going to be able to clear that
mountain if you don't make any changes
to find out the first thing we need to
do is find our pressure altitude we can
either spin our altimeter over to 2992
and check what the altimeter is reading
or we can simply subtract our current
altimeter setting of
3012 from the standard pressure of
29.92 when we do that we get a.2 so
let's turn that into thousands of feet
by moving the decimal to the right three
places and now we subtract 200 ft from
10,500 to get a pressure altitude of
10,300 Ft next let's say that at se
level it's 0° if we use a standard laps
rate that would mean the temperature up
here at 10,000 ft is
-20° so now let's see if we can clear
this mountain okay for this we'll use
this little window right here we set our
pressure altitude was 10,300 and that's
somewhere right here and we'll rotate
the temperature of -20° right across
from that now our true altitude will be
on the outer scale and our calibrated
altitude will be on the inner scale
let's see if we want to miss the top of
this mountain at a true altitude of
10,000 ft we need to see an indicated
altitude of 10,550 Ft what did we say
our indicated altitude was we said it
was 10,500 ft so if you're flying in the
clouds at 10,500 ft and you think you're
good you just smacked right into the
side of that mountain 50 ft below the
peak it's crazy how these altimeters can
give our minds a false sense of security
is aren't possibly some kind of thoughts
that are being projected into your mind
possibly by extraterrestrials and
remember calibrated altitude doesn't
account for any minor instrument error
that your altimeter might have these
errors could change things a feet one
way or another okay so one of the thing
you're going to want to know how to do
is to convert your true air speed to
your calibrated air speed as I mentioned
earlier how fast you're traveling
through the air around you or your true
air speed is directly related to your
pressure altitude and the temperature
this works almost exactly like the true
altitude conversion but this time we'll
be using this window over here let's say
we're still flying at our pressure
altitude of 10,300 ft and the
temperature is still -20° up here what
is our true air speed if we're seeing an
indicated air speed of 118 knots well
before we can use our flight computer we
need to convert our indicated air speed
to calibrated air speed and to do that
we need to dig out our air speed
calibration table from the PO okay so if
I'm seeing 110 knots indicated that
means my calibrated air speed is 107
knots and if I'm flying 120 my
calibrated air speed
is7 in both cases I would subtract three
knots and my air speed of 118 knots
Falls in in between those so let's
subtract 3 knots from 118 to get a
calibrated air speed of 115 knots next
let's dig out the flight computer and
start with our temperature and air
pressure window here we'll find our
pressure altitude of
10,300 and then we can rotate our
temperature of -20° over to that now we
simply find our calibrated air speed of
115 knots on the inner ring and we look
across to find our true air speed is
just under 131 knots true as you can see
this is pretty simple and we're going to
do another one of these here in just a
minute but now that we know how to find
our true air speed let's flip over the
flight computer and talk about the
winding side the winding side is
extremely easy to use the only thing you
need to remember is that you need to do
all the steps in the correct order and
you can't leave out any of the steps or
the information it gives you won't be
right now the important thing to keep in
mind about the winding side of the WIS
willll is that it gives us two things it
gives us a WI correction angle and our
ground speed if you're flying from cersi
airport over to West Memphis you would
need to fly a true course of 093 in
order to stay on track the whole entire
route but if you want to maintain that
course you'll have to crab into the wind
as you fly but how much should you crab
Into The Wind that depends on two things
the wind speed and the wind direction
let's say the wind along my route is
going to be 040 at 13 knots which way
would I need need to crab into the wind
to stay on course Well we'd have to crab
slightly to the left what about a wind
of 20 at 7 knots in this case we would
have a slight Tailwind but we would have
to crab slightly to the right to stay on
course and that's all this thing is
doing is telling you how much to crab
into the wind because you always have to
point your nose into the wind if you
want to stay on course the other thing
this gives us is our ground speed our
ground speed is the result of two things
our true air speed and the wind if our
true air speed is 120 knots and we have
a direct headwind of 20 knots our speed
over the ground or ground speed is now
100 knots the opposite is true for a
Tailwind if I have a direct Tailwind of
10 knots and my true air speed was 120
my ground speed is now 130 knots The
Whiz wheel accounts for the angle of the
wind and gives us an accurate
measurement of our ground speed by
adding or subtracting our headwind
component it and it's still able to give
us these numbers when the winds are not
straight from the front or straight from
the back now let's see how this thing
works remember we need to make sure that
we do this in the correct order or this
thing is going to give us bad
information if you ever forget real E6
BS have the instructions written on them
start with your winds a loft forecast
let's say our winds are 20 at 7even
knots at our cruising altitude today
let's put that underneath this Mark that
reads true index now it's important to
remember that when's a LOF data is
always given in relation to True North
you'll need to convert everything to a
MAG heading before you go fly now let's
Slide the center mark up to a good
starting point I call this the pipper
there are no zeros on this thing so a
good number to start out with is 100
next let's make a mark seven knots up
for our wind speed on a real flight
computer you can draw an X with a pencil
and this works really well then we
simply rotate the compass card until our
true course is underneath the index here
and we said that was going to be 093 so
we'll throw that in here now and now we
have one more thing to do before this
thing gives us good information this
thing is completely wrong until you do
this last step we need to slide the Mark
we made earlier down to our true air
speed and let's go ahead and say that
was 131 knots from the calculations we
made earlier and it's extremely
important that you put your pencil mark
on the true air speed and not the pipper
if you do this your answer is going to
be wrong now we simply read our ground
speed under the pipper and it looks to
me like a ground speed is going to be
133 knots and now you'll notice
something kind of cool this line in the
center here is the true course our
airplane's going to be flying and this
Mark we made earlier and this line
represents the direction the wind is
going to be coming from so you can see
that we're going to have a quartering
right Tailwind on this flight now we
need to know how much we need to crab
into the wind and all we have to do here
is to look at these marks running up and
down on this chart these are marked in
increments of two degrees but on some
Wiz Wheels they may be marked every one
degree so now we can see that we need to
crab to the right 0 2 three 3 degrees
and if you're trying to update your true
course to a true heading you want to add
the numbers on the right of the scale
and you would want to subtract the
numbers on the left side of the scale
notice on The Compass Card how the
numbers get bigger on the right and they
get smaller on the left this is an easy
way to remember this now let's solve a
small cross country problem let's say
I'm flying back to Carlile Municipal
from West Memphis and it took me six
minutes to get to my top of climb at
4,500 ft MSL according to my PO once I
reach my cruise speed I should be
traveling at 109 knots true and my
winded altitude is 220 at 14 knots how
long is it going to take me to get to my
destination total let's take another
look at the winding side of this fight
computer once again we'll start with the
wind because this is the winding side of
the fly computer so let's put our wind
direction up here that was
220 then we'll move the pipper up to 100
and make a mark for our wind speed 14
knots up from the center now let's
rotate our flight computer until we hit
our true course this time our true
course is going to be
256 once that's set we'll rotate the
Mark we made down to our true air speed
of 109 knots and we can read our ground
speed underneath the pipper it looks
like our ground speed is going to be 97
knots I can see that I'm going to have a
headwind coming from the front left so I
need to crab my airplane to the left to
stay on course it looks like I'll be
subtracting 0 2 4° from my true course
to get a true heading of 252 de and now
to change that over to a MAG heading
I'll look down at the isogonic line on
the sectional to see that I need to add
one degree of Wester variation to fly a
magnetic heading of
253 and today I'm flying a fancy 172 SP
with the G1000 in it so there's no
deviation in this plane because this guy
uses magnetometers to sense the magnetic
fields in this area so I don't need to
make any Compass deviation Corrections
so that will make my final course
heading
253 and that's going to be really
important for this flight but that's not
the question we were trying to find the
answer to we're trying to figure out the
total time it's going to take us to get
to our destination well if it's 75
nautical miles to our destination and it
took us 8 miles to get to our top of
climb that means we have 67 miles to go
let's go back to the front side of our
flight computer and find our ground
speed on here we set our ground speed
was 97 knots so let's rotate the inner
ring until the rate triangle lines up
with 97 now let's find our distance of
67 mil on the outer ring and we'll read
our time underneath that it looks like
it's going to take us
41.5 minutes to go those 67 miles so
what's the total time it's going to take
us well don't forget to add the time it
took us to get to our top of climb we
said that it was going to take 6 minutes
so
41.5 + 6 equals 47.5 minutes so it's
going to take us 47 minutes and 30
seconds total for this trip now what if
I took off with 12 gallons of fuel in
the tanks would I be legal to fly all
the way to my destination now I know
you're thinking why would you do that I
mean that's pretty stupid but would I be
legal well according to the PO we're
going to be burning 8.5 gallons per hour
with the current conditions so let's set
up our flight computer and see I'll put
8.5 under the rate here then I'll look
for 41.5 minutes on the inner scale
looks like we're going to be burning
about 5.9 gallons of fuel from our top
of climb to our destination then if we
add 1. 5 gallons for the fuel will burn
during the climb and the 1.4 gallons
will burn for start taxi and takeoff
we're looking at 8.8 gallons we took off
with 12 gallons of fuel and we're going
to burn
8.8 that leaves us with 3.2 gallons of
fuel and we need to land with 30 minutes
of fuel and we're burning 8.5 gallons
per hour so half of that is
4.25 so are we legal no we're not but
would it be legal if we put 1.05 gallons
of fuel fuel on the plane before we took
off that would make us land with exactly
4.25 Gall so technically yes it would be
legal but what it be
smart hey nudge nudge okay so now let's
take this a little bit further I went
ahead and put one and a half extra
gallons in my plane to be legal for this
little cross country so now how do I
know that I'm making good time and that
I'm actually flying a ground speed of 97
knots this is important to know because
if our ground speed is slower than 97
knots it's going to take me longer to
get to my destination and I can't afford
to be late because I put the minimum
amount of fuel in my airplane and I'm
burning 8.5 gallons per hour well one
way is to calculate your ground speed
every time you pass over a waypoint like
we've already done but another way is to
find the indicated air speed that we
should be flying and see if we're
getting the indicated air speed that we
expected to find our indicated air speed
we need to start with our ground speed
and work the winding problem backwards
we set our wind was 220 at 14 knots so
we'll put that here in our flight
computer and we'll make our Mark 14
knots above the 100 for our wind speed
then rotate the wheel back to our true
course of
256 now up until this point everything's
been the same as before except this time
we know our ground speed but not our
true air speed so let's put the pipper
on the ground speed of 97 knots and
you'll read your true air speed
underneath the mark you made when you
work these problems the pipper always
always goes on your ground speed and the
mark you make will be your true air
speed now we can see that our true air
speed is 109 knots and had we written
that down earlier when we did these
calculations let's say on a nav log or
something we wouldn't have had to do
this again now let's convert that to our
indicated air speed remember the first
step in doing that is to get our
calibrated air speed so let's flip over
the flight computer to get that let's
say the temperature at altitude is 15° C
and our pressure altitude is 4,000 ft
once these are lined up we simply find
our true air speed of 109 knots on the
outer scale and it looks like our
calibrated air speed is going to be1
knots now we go back to our air speeed
calibration chart to see that our
indicated air speed should be roughly
three knots faster than our calibrated
air speed so we should be seeing 104
knots on our air speed indicator when we
fly this cross country if our speed's
faster that means we'll get there sooner
if our speed is slower then this is
going to affect our ground speed and now
I'm starting to get worried about fuel
because I took the bare minimum because
I'm a ninka poop now I know this all
seems kind of complicated but here are
some big takeaways when it comes to
getting air speed information that's
actually useful for flight the two air
speeds that you need to use in flight
are your ground speed and your indicated
air speed true air speed and calibrated
air speed are important but you won't
know what these are unless you calculate
them or you have a fancy airplane that
calculates them for you so if you want
to know the ground speed you're getting
you have to work backwards from your
indicated air speed to your calibrated
air speed to your true air speed to get
your ground speed if you know your
ground speed but you want to find your
indicated air speed you need to work
these in the opposite direction to
figure that out and by keeping that in
mind and working through these problems
methodically that will make it easier to
solve them okay now I want to show you
how to do one more thing with the Wiis
wheel because it might come in handy on
your written exam and that's how to
calculate the actual when you're getting
up at altitude let's say you're flying a
ground track or a true course of
256 but in order to stay on course you
have to fly a magnetic heading of
264 your ground speed is 135 knots and
your true air speed is 123 knots what
are my actual winds to solve this
problem we first need to find our true
heading in this area our variation is 1°
West now normally West is best so you
would add 1 Dee to get your magnetic
heading but when you're working
backwards like this you would do the
opposite so we would subtract one de to
give us a true heading of
263 now let's find our wind correction
angle our true heading is 263 now we
need to subtract our true course of 256
from that to give us a wind correction
angle of
7° and since this number is positive
that means it's 7° to the right now
let's subtract our true air speed from
our ground speed 35 - 123 = 12 now let's
pull out the wiiz wheel now remember
we're completely working backwards this
time to find the wind so we need to
start with our true course this time
under the true index and we said that
was
256 then let's put our pipper on our
ground speed of 135 knots remember no
matter what the pipper always goes on
your ground speed now we need to find
where a wind correction angle of 7° to
the right and our true air speed of 100
23 knots intersect and put our Mark
right there once we do that we simply
rotate our Mark until it's centered on
our true course line and to make it
easier to read you can slide the pipper
down to the 100 Mark if you want then
you can read your wind direction under
the true index looks like our winds are
0 27° and the speed of the wind is
exactly 20 knots so winds at altitude
are 027 at 20 knots pretty amazing right
and now you know how to use the old wiiz
will and as you can see it's a powerful
little tool that you can use on your
cross country flights when you're
concerned about time Fuel and distance
and now that you've wasted your time
learning about alien technology in my
next video I'm going to explain why you
actually don't need one of these things
you can do all these calculations
without an e6b and in a lot of cases
it'll actually be faster and more
accurate to do so when that video is
available I'll put it right here smash
like before you watch the next one and
I'll see you over there
airra calling
position
well story's over